if you want to hear about all the
references Annabel creation has to the
directors old the YouTube videos then
I'll stick around to the end of this
video welcome back to things you missed
on the last episode I preached about
some of the things you know - in the
original anime so today I'll be putting
together the pieces of the 2017 prequel
Annabel creation this video is special
because this is the first time in
covering a movie made by a fellow
youtuber this film was directed by David
F Sandberg who goes by pony smasher on
YouTube his most well known video was
lights out which got him the job to make
the feature film version here's a photo
of me being weird at the premiere at
VidCon 2016 the lead actress of this
film is to Letha Bateman who's the
brother of Gabriel Bateman from lights
out Annabel creation opens with the shot
of a doll eyeball in mr. Mullens toy
shop this image foreshadows the fate of
his wife who lost her left eye after
being attacked by the demon and wears a
porcelain mask to cover it up this sign
formal in stoic company describes the
figures as handcrafted fine dolls and we
later see that there were only a hundred
of them in existence this is actually
the director's handwriting the number 1
right here he explains this in his
behind the scenes on his youtube channel
but I think this also helps answer a
question from the first one which is why
this particular doll is so rare the
real-life quote-unquote Haunted doll
described in the Warrens Case Files is a
common Raggedy Ann doll the sign also
says that this doll is available at
palmeri's toy shop a reference to the
Palmeri apartments in the original
Annabelle we've talked about how that
original film naturally drew some
inspiration from the previous king of
creepy doll movies child's play which I
have a whole series of things you missed
videos on I found this opening to the
second Annabelle film to be very
reminiscent of the opening of child's
play to both essentially showing the
creation of the doll mr. Mullens his
daughter B plays hide-and-seek with him
and her hiding spot is behind the
curtain by the window after her death
the demon uses her likeness on many
occasions which could explain why it
hides in the same spot in Mia's
apartment in Annabelle and why it uses
the record player to mess with its
victims 12 years after Bea's death the
Mullins is decided to take in a group of
orphan girls and we meet Linda and
Janice on the bus ride over she does
know that that's not read rights the
older girls in the front of the bus are
reading modern teen magazine and this
one's
really into it they arrived and meets
mr. Mullens and the front door of the
house has both traditional and inverted
crosses perhaps a clue about the forces
of good and evil at play beyond these
doors when the girls tour the house it's
one big long tracking shots just like
this shot in the conjuring which this
movie is a spin-off of and the curse of
liya Dona or as I call it Spanish the
Kandra also a part of the series in the
behind-the-scenes videos Pony Smasher
described a shot that took 12 takes and
I'm guessing that this is it on Anabel
creation I think the most we ever did
was 12 takes but that was for a long
Steadicam shot with eight different
actors and it was pretty complicated mr.
Mullens introduces Janice to the
chairlift which is very slow I felt like
I was waiting for king zora to get out
of the way again there's also a brief
moment where Bea's image can barely be
seen in the background during the night
Janice realizes the door to be his room
is somehow unlocked and wanders in there
against mr. Mullens his orders where she
discovers that the Annabelle doll is
locked in the closet surrounded by Bible
pages after the closet door continues to
open on its own she throws a blanket
over the doll as she continues to
explore the room it comes for her and
corners her but when the blanket falls
away it's revealed that there was
nothing underneath this is a direct
reference to David Sandberg short-film
attic panic on the pony smash her
YouTube channel
[Music]
later in the movie when the teenage girl
Carolyn gets stuck in the barn there's
another idea lifted from attic panic
which is the lightbulb when storing
itself considering how many feature
films have stolen his concept from
lights out I'm glad he was able to use
this stuff from attic panic before
somebody else did he also got the
orchestra to include a cover of the
simple soundtrack that he created for
the short this would not be the only
reference to his own shorts in the movie
the nun who's in charge of all of the
girls is named sister Charlotte and in
one scene she shows mr. Mullins a
photograph of her time in Romania where
he went out an older nun in the
background that she doesn't recognize
this is actually valid the nun demon and
the antagonist of the conjuring 2 and of
course the not witch Annabel for Asians
post-credit scene is a teaser for
in the scene where the two older girls
are gossiping under the sheet and
they're attacked by something they end
up saying that it looked like mrs.
Mullins but if you actually pause on
that moment it doesn't look like her or
her mass it just appears to be a generic
porcelain mask with dark eyes it kind of
gives me the purge vibes
maybe this image will be expanded on in
another movie Janice discovers a picture
of be in the hallway and brings it into
her room to look at it when she puts it
in a dark spot the eyes give off a
demonic glow and the same effect is used
later on where we see the possessed form
of Janice this is the same effect that's
used throughout Sandberg's feature film
version of lights out on the main
antagonist Diana there are a number of
visuals that reference Bea Bea is the
nickname that the Mullins had given to
their daughter which is short for her
full name Annabel and I think this might
be an intentional parallel to the first
film where we constantly see the letter
A in this one there's an image of Abby
on her window in her old room B's on the
vertical post holding up the railing
alongside the stairs and when Linda
looked through this kaleidoscope this is
what she sees which is similar to the
stereotypical Hollywood interpretation
of what Abby's point of view might look
like I looked it up and they don't
actually see a bunch of repeat images
that's only in the movies
remember that slow chair that I
mentioned earlier you didn't think that
wasn't gonna come back did you in fact I
think the scene where the chair gets
stuck with Janice on it and the demon
lurking nearby is another throwback to
the original Annabel where Mia gets
stuck on the elevator that won't go up
with the demon lurking about in the
storage area when we learn the story of
how the doll essentially got possessed
it's very similar to what happened to
the nurses after the events of Annabelle
with the demon pretending to be at the
spirit of the little girl named
Annabelle asking permission to move into
the doll and then causing violent
attacks little girl Linda realizes that
there's something evil on the doll and
tries to get rid of it by throwing it in
the well in the middle of the night and
well this happens
[Music]
it's another callback to one of the
short films on David's channel this one
a 2014 flaky called coffer Rolex
[Music]
so we find out how mrs. Mullins was
injured by the demon posing as their
daughter's ghost but it's too late
because the demon Malthus gets to both
mr. and mrs. Mullins causing the girls
to try to escape the house they get into
the car but have some trouble starting
it's causing the headlights to blink on
and on and they notice the Scarecrow
move in between light flashes which of
course is a callback to lights out at
the end of the day sister Charlotte is
able to lock the demonically is that a
word demonically possessed Janice in the
closet where she disappears through the
wall but the other girls are safe at
least they put the doll which has
supposedly been purged of all evil by
this dude in the back of the police car
which drives away past the grave of B
where this all started so this goes back
to that whole question from the last
video how did the doll go from this cop
car to John purchasing it and giving it
to Mia
the demon Malthus has to have something
to do with it our final sequence takes
place at st. and Joachim orphanage
Joakim is not only a reference to the
one of the great Bulls players from the
2000s but also a biblical reference to
the father of Mary which makes sense
because of the themes of their church
versus the evil demons that persist
throughout this franchise the woman
working at the orphanage is l'hotel
Austin the wife of David Sandberg she
stars in I think all of his short films
and cameos in all of his features the
Higgins family who you'll remember from
the original Annabelle comes to adopt
Janice who turns out to be the daughter
that comes back to kill them and
sacrifice them for Malthus years later
when they first meet her they give her a
gift it's an actual Raggedy Ann doll get
another parallel to the original
Annabelle which also has this doll
featured in its epilogue if you were to
visit the actual Warren Museum this is
the doll that you'd find in the glass
case
Annabelle creation ends as many
controversies do with a slow push in on
the central object of this movie in this
case of course the Annabelle doll
Silverstein Annabelle's past we've seen
Annabelle's origin so join me next time
on things you miss to see Annabelle's
future because we're gonna be covering
at the newest film Annabelle comes home
remember to subscribe to see ZZZ world
so you don't miss it make sure you bring
the death Bell for
occasions and I'll see you in the next
one assuming we both survive
[Music]